le sapin les cadeaux le père noël mariah
carey c'est très bien doit-on rappeler
qu'à la base noël est une fête
chrétienne
la célébration de la naissance du christ
loin de moi l'idée de tout prosélytisme
simplement
pendant que certains déballent leurs
cadeaux achetés sur amazon et dégustent
un foie gras du périgord
d'autres subissent massacré persécution
en raison de leur foi
depuis 1993 les ong portes ouvertes
publie chaque année l'index mondial de
persécution des chrétiens
un classement des 50 pays où les
chrétiens rencontrerait les plus grandes
difficultés en raison de leur religion
cette année encore le rapport annuel de
cette ong fondée en 1955 aux pays bas et
qui possède une vingtaine de bureaux à
travers le monde risquent d'être morbide
le nombre de chrétiens tués dans le
monde en 2020 dépassera
vraisemblablement les 4000 le nombre de
victimes était de 2 1983 en 2019
cette année-là 3711 chrétiens étaient
détenus dans le monde et 9488 églises
étaient fermés détruites ou ciblés par
des attaques principalement islamistes
rien qu'au nigeria depuis 2015 quatre
mille chrétiens ont été assassinés par
boko haram dont 500 prêtres exécuté dans
l'état du borno
principale cible des jihadistes et puis
2020 c'est aussi le haut karabagh et ces
images insoutenables d'arméniens
chrétiens de l'artsakh décapité humilié
massacrés par des hommes portant
fièrement l'uniforme de l'azerbaïdjan ce
sont des croix renversées et des églises
profanées
malgré les promesses du président azéri
ilham aliev qui a assuré à maintes
reprises que les églises chrétiennes
dans le haut-karabagh faisait partie du
patrimoine historique de la région et ne
serait pas menacée curieusement la
situation dramatique du haut karabagh a
relativement peu été relayée dans les
médias hexagonaux plus que cela certains
sans même considérer que l'indignation
face à des exactions et des persécutions
visant des chrétiens fêtent tenez vous
bien le jeu de l'extrême droite
l'article de libération à ce sujet a été
supprimée temporairement selon la
rédaction qui assure qu'il s'agit d'une
mise en stand by en quelque sorte pour
ne pas compliquer la tâche d'une de ses
journalistes sur le terrain
effectivement ça doit être compliqué
donné une interview à un média puis
découvrir un article de ce même média
qui t'explique que ceux qui soutiennent
la cause que tu défends sont des
fascistes s'adonnent pas hyper envie de
continuer le dialogue en chine où le
christianisme s'est secrètement
développé au fil des ans le nombre de
chrétiens détenus et d'églises ciblé a
été multiplié par dix en dix ans à côté
de la persécution des ouïgours dénoncé à
juste titre la situation des chrétiens
aussi se détériore au moyen-orient la
situation est extrêmement compliqué en
irak les chrétiens et des 1,5 million en
2003 ils sont deux cents mille
aujourd'hui les chrétiens de syrie sont
désormais 700 milles contre 2,2 millions
avant la guerre civile les coptes
continue d'être persécutés en egypte
même si le pouvoir combat officiellement
les islamistes
le rapport de l' ong portes ouverts de
janvier 2019 avait rapporté que 260
millions de chrétiens était je cite
fortement persécutés à travers le monde
l'année 2020 est-ce que d'être encore
plus dur joyeux noël à tous prenez soin
de vous